slumped and one doesn't take you out so
you got a string together mate so this
is the right direction
no look cauley-stein muscles it up and
in over Mickey D's first basket in four
tries he's shooting only 41% from the
floor this year really polished and a
lot of times the you settles grant
you're like I can make this nice pass
and goes back to the Kings again he
missed it eight seconds left box Kings
breakout faculty Begley the flying duck
by Marvin Bagley 69 64 if they don't
like too difficult lose buddy hield
from the Aaron Fox this is a clinic
we're watching right now Aaron Fox says
the over plans on the front side I got
the backside covered in blood he healed
took the basket catching a nice little
delivery no basket it was on the ball
[Applause]
bringing it home that was the fifth foul
on Harry Giles now alter its posting Oh
loses it Fox
oh boy but he dials in go-go-gadget says
Willie Fox finds Willie who had his man
pinned and it's 15-6 nice setup
cauley-stein that is seventh assist for
deer and poppies they all hit the glass
they know exactly what they want to do
is Paulie Stein knows what he wants to
do well so does beer and box I want to
get out into the open court where that's
Reuters playing some tough defense
here's buddy
[Applause]
nine buddy him with 23 points with the
rebound Fox
look out go look at the ball oh we
talked about electricity look at that
move and pack then again he's been
scoring too but I mean you're gonna
really need him to guard ingles
oh what a pass that was fight the Aaron
Fox a thing of beauty see right here mid
move oh I see you there you go
take this hot pepperoni pie and put it
in a bucket then 14 seconds after a
offensive rebound Fox spitting there we
used to be a league with the ball in his
hands razzle dazzle drops it off bolita
delivers for two we play he's got five
and it's a one-point lead for Sacramento
Fox this past the Willie beautifully
done in the basket another assist with
the Aaron Fox little movement ball his
body and some execution by the Kings
Willie makes the catch and as the basket
box with the assist his sixth but finds
them starting to use his speed all the
things that he brings to the game still
a mess
shot clock at 14 Fox to heal
[Applause]
funny healed we'll put it up it in there
comes Fox but they don't waste a lot of
time time for Fox you should see how
animated Yeager was after that made
basket by Colin re
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
nice tall movement and then looking to
play hit slots away be elites into the
floor oh look at that pass by box the
Buddy hield that's incredible
great defense by the Kings get active
hands I think just fit hands fighting
here and any just beautiful baby fox
nicely done left-handed scoop pass just
throw it out fully handle the beer and
give them multiple opportunities well
you know what Willy beat everyone down
the floor nice job i Willie cauley-stein
at Fox bounding box gets by sends up to
be elite so oh what a set up again by
box who is once again showing everyone
fourth quarter it's my ball game 103 93
we're past the halfway mark rebounding
here in the first quarter 11 to 2 in
favor of the thunders yes what phase do
grant and this is what what he here does
he's at the scores table he's making a
very early entrance nice pass the
adjustment and the basket by Willie
cauley-stein cauley-stein quickly up the
floor look at Jackson runs out and gets
the basket big year
this is port awareness to look up the
floor nice look up the floors you said
well as he's grabbing it he's already
looking up the floor JJ knows what to do
get out in the open court
[Music]
Jackson cuts Fox finds him and the
basket
beautifully done right there a single
will do but the Kings are looking for a
home run over the wall
look at this pass that thing is on a
rope right there buddy hield reached up
knocked down and one may be the success
for the king sent home has just pulled
out by nineteen every game Davis on him
again
here he is to the baseline the shuffle
and the bested by Willie cauley-stein
bucks just perfection on that plate
[Applause]
zubats no-good box dribbles out of a
crab beautiful box Bernardino timeout
Lakers you can't do it much better than
out 72-69
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he'll just did outrun ball yeah I mean
you said you got it but he said you got
it
Willie says I've got out of goods Agra
where's number 19 you will not get out
work for your buck Donna [ __ ] away from
the defense of Ceylon a store Fox steals
the ball cauley-stein look out below
this is how you win because he didn't
complain he just goes down and let's
let's be up again
102 92 Fox setting up cauley-stein
beautifully now it's brown and again
you're right they are standing behind a
line and firing the Alicia Fox with a
beautiful pass yeah he's become really
good at that as well how about that and
a chance for a three-point play
bottom misses don't jump what do you
think and Willie up a books nice pass
Willie with a basket
this evening these guys fortunate there
thought yes they did you got to get the
ball in the paint grant the lob step
finish that was beautiful 102 96 minutes
left box the lead oh how I hurt as Harry
Giles do that grants you can see Harry
Giles he's pointing up lobbed it lobbed
at and that is the connection between
the point guard look at him he's
pointing up telling the air and exactly
what he wants to do
there will be no comeback tonight by the
Blazers call the Stein from Fox 68-62
with 520 left that's a foul
goodness a lot of contact right there
Willie cauley-stein delivers up the
basket though earring there with that
shot - box on the board set up 4840
[Applause]
that's a four-point swing Simmons up the
lung now watch this look ahead from D
Aaron Fox finds Harry Giles and Harry
finds some twine at the bottom of the
ring that steal walk it down for the
final possession of the hat
[Music]
how beautiful was that and a chance for
a three-point play
missed it will it change that a little
bit bucks via Lisa boy how quick was
that he hear her boxes simply re fade
away unable to get the walls as John
Collins as box are about to put on a
little
[Music]
just saw that awesome John Collins done
he is going to be in the ATT slam-dunk
contest as Jason Jay
[Music]
about the process and it's about to be
the Derek Fox show
there was a very difficult fast all
right let's take another beautiful pass
by foxes set you're right get them to
that go fast during if we'd have any
rust after a week off the answer is No
Paul D Stein thank you very much from
the air and Fox
[Music]
[Applause]
boy how about Corey Brewer 9999 she do
and even more than that as we look at
this right here Corey Brewer and no
hesitation down a deep ball cutting to
the basket and Fox finds the Oklahoma
sooner so called and he's got four here
in the early going
the law Oh Willie cauley-stein on a
beautiful set up by Fox
good luck
[Applause]
Big Shot right here
box nice shuffle pass and a chance for a
three-point play
and it's day 13 fountain grant you don't
have to shoot the three put it on the
floor you get it the old-fashioned way
the point is you make sure that you bat
pass pops nice pass
five-point game Williams usually finds
Daryl but earrings box gets out uses his
pivot 14 to 8 as the Kings down 60th
7:30 left cauley-stein again well he
calls
boys Tatum and look at this buddy hield
leaks out and a two-for-one situation is
executed perfect clicks with a good
finish
perhaps you two a slow first water and
you can test it any better than Fox just
good to be elites a five-point game and
he led him to a basket right they won't
make both teams really struggling from
three in this game Mary Giles on a
beautiful feed from the errant box and
that's the seventh assist per box 6866
and pick and rolls turn a corner get
down just box is open vines cauley-stein
and there it is you want on the dung
heap dump the one-point game pal
California and he has come on defender
three and D type of guy that Danny Ainge
hasn't made a lot of mistakes
built himself a heck of a team that got
draft picks to the Kings to chip in to
this little bit before the Hat
especially with this starting rule
nice
it's the cauley-stein 7271 oh nice
little slip
especially deep shooters and things
haven't exploited that part of it back
Lee says thank you very much the iron
fox
well fox is simply on his own broke down
the defense received the errand in the
open court really just the splits of
defense lines Marvin Bagley nice pass
Brooklyn gets but they're not gonna have
Betty left pretty footer that Donovan
[Applause]
and Rick Carlisle now takes the time out
what a difference when he is shooting
the ball well the elites are not good
away Fox steps on the gas pedal here he
goes finds Barnes and the cup and put it
in the pump and set them ton alive it's
all good and then Harrison Barnes with
the run-out in for 45 left and Willie
from Fox
yes yep
sure see a piece Mason but a mention you
have some winter coats up there in
Wisconsin
there is a three ball by Corey Brewer
104 101 be right there and in a
beautiful swing pass right there to
Corey Brewer three-ball corner now he
drives it away but none of it saves
Kings down for on the bull can't expect
them to shoot the same percentage for me
as they did in the first half which was
incredible oh what a pass how about the
Aaron Fox getting that ball I had the
buddy here and creativity on the block
the second time you seen this right here
though you haven't seen this one before
that was just right on the money to put
a year sheet is all allowance and can't
really say much
[Music]
[Applause]
Barnes that's his first basket of the
game sneering [ __ ] right here getting
his paint create a little shot right
there for Harrison Barnes and it's
packing with the rebound it doesn't take
long for him to get one no to dance
box he's got buddy open and it's 2922
taking a lot of time got to have this
the phallus what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content